hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
John old Humphrey all right let's get it
over with one of her top reward tiers is
whatever video you request on patreon we
must definitely do and put up on the
youtubes and today's top rewards here
request comes from a man named Andrew
Hayes Andrew let's get sincere for a
moment you're one of my favorite people
in the world dude yeah you were on this
channel a few months ago and meeting you
in person was such a joy such a delight
you seemed a little bit nervous but I
was a little bit nervous too though so
used to just seeing you on the screen
he's guy has a great YouTube channel and
he's been unbelievably supportive and
every time I talk to this guy just feel
so much joy like I'm always happy to
communicate with him I never feel this
sense of discomfort whatsoever and I
feel like weirdly empowered when I
chitchat with the guy so Andrew I Love
You Man and please go show him some
support and check out his youtube
channel and today he's requesting top 10
things you missed in wreck-it Ralph -
Ralph breaks the Internet at our patreon
or your TV show reaction watch the long
sneezy video coverage and weekly Q&A is
so go check us out hit him play it's
pretty terrible
[Music]
I'm looking for Steve Urkel who was by
Jaleel White on family matters yes eight
seasons on the disney-owned
ABC television network the legendary
video game characters Sonic the Hedgehog
on occasion in the 90s
and though the blue blur actually does
make an on-screen appearance in wreck-it
Ralph - voiced by his voice actor of
several years Roger Craig Smith you
can't help but wonder if this was the
filmmakers way of tipping the hat to
Sonics oh gee voice actor 9 youtube
voice actors the filmmakers clearly did
their homework on internet culture yes
they actually enlisted real-life YouTube
personalities to lend their voices
Michael Green Simon million subscribers
already scanned up and interviews in the
Internet in school she becomes a literal
cartoon character who loses access to
Internet number eight the anti princess
song whereas the other Disney Princesses
dream of living happily ever after in a
magical kingdom
vanellope wishes to spend the rest of
her days in salons really overly scald
slaughter race which is anything but a
traditional Disney Princess on this
especially hilarious is that as songs
music was composed by Alan Menken the
same man gave us part of your world a
whole new world and others on top of
that Sarah Silverman seems this song
with gal gadot who's known for play
and another unconventional princess
that's who even when he's given the most
minor of roles after Jason Mantzoukas
never fails to produce comedic gold
during the oh my Disney sequence from
Ralph breaks the internet and Zubaz
voices an obnoxious fan of a Q&A session
who has a bone to pick with baby Groot
where will you consider that many
suitcases character is named hey nah man
for those who don't know he no man is a
rather nice reference to comedy bang
bang which started as a podcast that
inspired a TV series of the same name
heungsu cos has frequently appeared on
the podcast where he coined his
catchphrase which derive from in 2017
several references to the battle royale
game can even be found in this movie in
one of the subtler instances a fortnight
is in a period of two weeks is cleverly
mentioned as yes explains how videogame
characters tend to rake in lots of likes
you can spot a familiar battle bus on
her tablet the most ingenious Easter Egg
ball comes when rouse performs the floss
dance which initially stemmed from
rustle backpack kid Horning and reached
an another level of popularity knocked
up in fortnight number 5 can't
understand Merida
[Music]
I understood at this cake she was trying
to get across kind of hard to understand
she's from the other studio according to
Merida was the first Pixar character to
be featured among Disney's official
princess line so it's not surprising
that her words for the internet however
is that he passed away at age 95 just
over a week before the film's release
he sadly didn't get to see the film
released before his death but this cameo
further demonstrates why his legacy will
last forever
number three Disney characters
everywhere no I what is involved
the most houses umbrella but you need a
keen eye to catch them all upon arriving
vanellope not only crosses paths with a
or but also spots the likes of Dumbo
Ironman Kermit the Frog Eve r2d2 and
Mickey Mouse just a name a few
what area features attractions dedicated
to baymax and Buzz Lightyear when the
user who looks an awful lot like Darth
Maul passing by on the run from skull
tubers vennett will be even encounters
getting wild grumpy
hey hey the Brewster ticker mouth and
Peter Pan's shadow oh really Wow gee
mystical Kingdom Hearts games look under
populated by comparison no DC
entertainments parent company so
naturally expected a DC character like
Batman to be referenced in anything
Disney related why did Disney Princesses
transition into their casual flowing
though the music cue plays sounds just
like Neil Hefty's iconic composition
from the 1960s Batman show he had West
series notably wasn't produced by Warner
Brothers
but 20th Century Fox will ever get
number one after credits
this might be heavily advertised was
excluded from the plot did surface in
the credits however the scene animator
Michelle Watson stated quote it was
meant to be part of the whole montage
where Ralph and vanellope explored the
Internet and then when the story shifted
it didn't really make sense anymore
he just loved it so much that we wanted
to make sure it was still shared the
credits Walter the scheme pika frozen -
Elsa singing let it go never going to
give you up I agree with most of your
pics yeah I did miss a few of these
things I was a little bit confused by
the first one how was that really like
much of an easter egg I'm not sure I
remember something about someone voicing
something in the new Urkel's being
mentioned that was a stretch yeah I mean
I just thought it was like Steve Urkel
is just a reference people pull you know
yeah or even Jaleel White is a reference
people pull because of Steve Urkel some
of the time I remembered that being in
the movie but I feel like Sonic it's a
bit of a stretch that's a coincidence I
think okay hard time keeping up with
what you meant by yeah I had no idea
about the YouTube stars that's so cool I
saw glozell in the in the IMDB but yeah
I didn't it didn't like fully click with
me and yeah the fact that they got a few
is pretty cool though they didn't reach
out to us or were not we're on the
Disney press list what I mean Danny
Fernandes I did see her tweet and I was
like oh that's pretty cool that Danny
Fernandes was featured in the movie but
I didn't realize that they pulled from
other people that's to me like a legit
Easter Egg yeah and if you know those
channels you probably hear the voices
and go yeah yeah like that's that's a
cool reference I mean some of these are
like so obvious Stanley yeah yeah I
remember that was pretty in my face
about it right yeah I don't think they
wanted to miss the
Penelope's singing the song was like
that was that was that an easter egg so
part of the song is that it's making fun
of Disney like they set it up that way
they make the jokes about not having a
song ya know like so of course she's
gonna have a song everything a linear
progression of the movie is just one of
the sequences that is a focus yeah you
know it's not even like it's a
background thing or like a thrown out
there moment it's like a full-on secret
yeah so it's really hard not to pick it
up like the whole audience clapped yeah
she was done singing arguably that's the
hardest the most memorable moment Jason
Mantzoukas I did not catch one that was
him and I've never heard this oh yeah
what's he called and a hang off hand
hang oh we're gonna hey hang on man yeah
hang on man or wait oh man yeah that bit
made me laugh the hardest out of
everything yeah I don't want to go
download the comedy bang bang podcast
it's weird to be thrown a podcast in the
middle of a video and be like I want to
keep listening to that I don't know that
was a thing it is cool cut Ralph breaks
internet does have all these Easter eggs
and canvases it's easy to walk away from
that film and think like ah the only
things I really missed her probably like
little details in the background but
there were things that were evidently
presented to me that I just did not
latch on to and I think that's pretty
cool to know that there were things
right there but because it's animated a
lot of its voice talent and everything
that other stuff I evidently did not
just see that was actually there yeah
and I feel like that's part of the fun
of I like that makes a ton of sense for
this particular movie in general because
of the internet yeah and yeah I feel
like that's kind of part of the major
fun I also didn't realize that brave
beat out I don't really watch the Oscars
I realize brave beat out wreck-it Ralph
which makes that cameo even cooler
actually yeah yeah I mean they're
willing to play nice about it and they
get their little backhanded like yeah
studio bit but yeah I thought that was
cute it's kind of like when Denzel
Washington be Russell Crowe at the
Oscars when they start a virtuosity
together prior to those nominations and
then they start an American Gangster
together pure mace I don't know what
it's exactly like that this is Disney's
American Gangster right here
that the Peter Pan shadow I didn't
notice like there were things here that
flat-out flew right past me the Batman
theme I think I noticed yeah and it did
pull me out for a hot second like yeah I
did have that moment did you have to
kill this yeah what weird loophole and
maybe the thing about Warner's not doing
the show is part of how that was
possible semantics yeah and that was
cool to learn about that mid-credits
scene because I did like that joke a lot
that occurs in the movie when they the
wind I forget who says it oh yeah that's
a little girl in the car right yeah a
map there's that they there wasn't a
scene in the movie that they put in the
trailer yeah they really go to show you
this famous scene from the trailer I
thought was really [ __ ] funny like
that's a cool way to play with the
audience yeah because this was one of
the most memorable scenes out of the
trailer to me and I forgot about it
actually like when the movie was done I
didn't even think like where was that
scene yeah but then that showed up and I
was like that's like a brilliant
self-aware joke yeah in this specific
movie that is very referential and has a
lot of self-awareness throughout yeah
it's appropriately meta and it also it's
just a cute way to package that up and -
yeah acknowledge the very real way
advertising works yeah and also that
joke would frozen - I didn't quite get
why that was such a funny joke oh yeah
yeah it's it's the rick roll thing is
just internet it's like the original
mean well no I know why that's funny I
meant I meant in terms of why that was
like hilarious to have that I think it I
didn't touch on it here but it kind of
hit me when I was watching that I
remember when the Coco came out they had
that like 20 minutes short film of
frozen play beforehand which was like
Jesus going off for so long full episode
of TV right yeah I thought they might
have kind of been poking fun at that a
little just a little bit where you think
you're gonna get another frozen extended
like you're watching Ralph breaks
internet and you're think you're gonna
get some T's for frozen again yeah we're
like you watch Coco and you get this
like giant tease were a totally separate
movie yeah
and then the end up getting that joke
instead yeah and good on y'all for
putting it at the end yeah
stead of at the top they mentioned
fortnight in here which the only
significance of that to me is I've seen
several comments on our video game
related videos just saying like if you
cover fortnight you'll get a million
more subscribers so apparently I carry
more about subscribers than the content
I don't I think we should have the
biggest sub count in the lowest views
pocket as long as we have subscribers
why talk about movies and only talk
about the games we want to talk about
like fortnight let's talk about for
another thing I've never heard of and
you feel the subs coming in this
conversation alright guys well thank you
as your request and thanks WatchMojo
this was a pretty good list and guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell download nothing
check us out on patreon yay bye